Yo, everybody!
I am so tired, but here I am.
I tech- Oh, no, I fucking rotated.
I- I finally fixed my sleep schedule.
But why am I still so tired?
I finally did it.
I slept at 11 p.m.
today.
Because I was so tired.
yesterday I was so the path I'm so I'm still I'm still
trying to fix past Doki's mistakes and I'm not done yet I
woke up at 6 a.m.
and it was back on the grind get back to work present Doki
you gotta repay past Doki's debts
Rise and shine!
You gotta pay off your debts!
Anyway, today we're gonna do a puzzle!
I've always wanted to do this challenge.
Luckily, this is a free game where you can make any puzzle
you want out of any picture.
So I've always wanted to do this challenge.
I mean, it wouldn't be more fun to do in real life, but then
also, So I think I love myself a little bit more.
I'm not yet descended into that level of resentment of
myself yet I don't hate myself that much yet But basically
It's a free steam game where you can make any puzzle you
want I've always wanted to do this challenge where you try
to complete a puzzle of a full white like not just white but
any solid color uh i chose white because i felt like that
one feels like the most self-inflicting pain i can do to me
and luckily um so far for this one uh it's just 200 pieces
that's the maximum amount i think that's the perfect amount
for me to do today uh so yeah that's really it i'm gonna do
a puzzle this is the type of streamer i am now i've i've
lost uh I've lost all content in my bone.
This is the type of content we're doing now.
I just do a puzzle.
That's it.
I've hit the bottom of the barrel.
I'm just going to fucking do a puzzle.
It's just, it's not like, there's no funny pictures on it.
It's just a white background.
See, I think there's like, the arrows.
streamers uh yes i've ran out of ideas uh ran of soon i'm
gonna watch pink dry
anyway uh oh i forgot the controls how do i move this okay
right click all right all right oh wait yeah that fits nice
all right we get the corners We got a corner of this.
Like a true variety streamer.
I do puzzles now.
I've hit that point in my life where I just do puzzles.
I heard some IRL streamers.
I don't know if they like...
I don't know if I can say they ran out of ideas.
Or it is a funny idea.
But there was like an IRL.
I saw like a clip.
of like irl streamers basically trying to find a needle in a
haystack so they spent the entire day for morning to night
to find a needle in a haystack like irl like i was just like
oh my i don't know if that's a brilliant idea or fucking
stupid i i can't tell wait why won't it go oh did it click I
think it clicked It's supposed to be here No, it's here Okay
There we go There we go I got one more corner Did they found
it?
Yeah, it was like the morning And then it was like pitch
black At the end Like at the end of the stream They did
found it And then you could Apparently if you like do a time
lapse You can literally see like It literally was the
morning Until the night At least they found it the last
corner oh my god thank god this is only 200 pieces i'm thank
god i was like only 200 and now i'm like thank god it's only
200.
uh i actually wanted to do that yet watching paint dry but
then someone beat me too I was like, oh my god, that's a
brilliant idea.
Why did I do it sooner?
Alright.
It's too slow.
Okay, maybe it's this.
Alright, it's not this.
Can't believe it.
Could have just watched paint dry.
I've just never watched paint dry.
It would have been a new experience for me.
I've never in my life watched paint dry before.
Is it fun?
Is it?
Wait, okay.
I know what's...
Oh my god.
I just need one piece to connect.
What?
Why?
It looks...
It literally is the exact shape.
There's no fucking way.
this doesn't connect it's literally the same shape oh my god
this is also the same shape oh my god it connected it there
you go all right that's not the same shape no it's not
boys i've never watched paint dry though Well, you have now
seen Pain Try.
It's watching Pain Try is an adventure of a lifetime.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think it's like a test of whether or not, like, who will
break first?
You or me.
I think that's the most ultimate test.
It's like, it's like, it's like, it's like, who is more
spiteful?
will i win out of spite or will i break first oh oh my god
connected i'm finding the there's so many pieces i don't
know how the fuck am i finding the right pieces okay like
would you guys survive longer out of spite or would i i'm
fueled by pure spite so i don't know guys terrible idea
watch a paint drive but each akka extends it out each you
mean each i know each ak i'm not staying there for like 20
days like like people have asked for uh people have asked
for more for sub-a-thons guys like that might as well be a
fucking sub-a-thon guys uh
for five minutes.
Each Akka extends the stream for five minutes.
You would break first.
Honestly, honestly, I won't be surprised.
I have a very short attention span.
Oh my god.
I literally already tried this puzzle piece.
I'm listening to some kumbaya song.
The public domain song from the game.
I mean, a free game.
The fact that I can make any puzzle.
Okay, it's not this corner.
Let's see.
Maybe this one looks...
Nah.
Is this?
Yeah!
Oh my god, I did it.
Look at that.
That's be this.
Okay, it's not this.
They're like the same, almost the same shape.
Thank god.
I was just like, man only 200 pieces uh-huh I can do two
thousand I can do a thousand there's like no you can't doki
no you actually like doing puzzles in real life well little
doki like doing it adult doki forgot all about it because I
would like actually uh my parents would actually buy puzzles
for me and I would just I've always wanted to like um but
then like the thing is I know we never did a thing where we
like glue the pieces together after completion and we just
like crumpled it all up.
I think the most pieces I've ever done was 5,000.
And I was like a kid.
I was a little jokie.
A little bird.
I don't know.
It was just relaxing.
I think it's also because my parents were like, uh, give her
a puzzle.
That'll take up most of her time and they won't, and she
won't bother us.
What should we do to preoccupy her time?
Give that girl a puzzle.
And they were right.
doing puzzles I you see I could I could have done anything
else instead I just sat there doing my puzzles that
was smart that was very smart of them before I mean to be
fair I was born in the generation before iPad kids were a
thing so like you know there was hope for me I think if I
was born during the iPad era, during iPad Kids era, I'd be
fucked.
This is like pre-iPad Kid era.
Imagine if I was born during iPad Kid era.
This could have got worse.
It could have been worse.
Oh, nice.
I expect that one to fit.
I'm just trial and erroring this.
Guys, it's turning...
I think I can see the vision of what this puzzle is supposed
to be.
Imagine.
Imagine...
Oh, I told you guys a story.
Like, how...
If I was, like, raised by Roblox or, like, I don't know,
Fortnite or some shit.
How, like...
kid like stole her credit card and spent I don't even
remember how much I don't know if I told you guys how much
she spent but it was a while ago and then like bought like X
amount of Robux with her mom with the mom's with his mom's
credit card and then she had to post and then she post on
Facebook being like what the fuck do I do and
my kids spent my money on Robux what do I do
I don't remember how much that kid spent It was a lot of
money though I remember It was a lot of fucking money
Because she had to borrow from my mom To be like Oh my god
Hi Doki, I missed your last stream So thanks for a really
hearty laugh And the April full stream The VOD was hilarious
Jugi, thank you, thank you, thank you Someone appreciated
sexy dokey.
Like, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Someone here appreciates the fine arts.
Fuck what puzzles do I do?
I do puzzles.
It is very relaxing, though.
Paid actor.
Here's your fine arts.
$5.
Yeah, I paid you gave $5 so you paid me $10 and I gave him
five Canadian and then he forgot about exchange rates Why
does no one okay?
I'll put the ones that don't fit on this board.
Maybe that'll be easier I feel like I've done this piece
like 20 times already surely there's more pieces.
Okay, there's another piece here Okay
okay i'll put wait unless no i've done that before like with
real puzzles as a kid i just forced it to get it i was like
it's your you two are supposed to connect what do you mean
the shape is perfect for it it's it's like when you're
trying to get a blue sky and then they're both also blue and
you're like there might as well be the right pieces
thank god i'm not an ipad kid i'm sorry for any ipad kids in
my chat but i think if i was born in that era i'd be like
mentally fucked because this is how i am without the ipad i
would have been so cooked yeah i would have not developed
the frontal cortex now i'm a jigsaw kid yeah i 100 would not
have a frontal cortex
That the brain has a special place for Pokemon.
Did you guys see that?
That Pokemon literally create...
Like, I thought that was crazy.
Like, finding that, uh...
Like, Pokemon is literally, like, physically ingrained in
our heads.
Yeah, so scientists had discovered...
Uh...
That, like, there's a special part in your brain that just
exclusively stores Pokemon knowledge like the fucking was it
called um the self-marketing they did it they preached the
defenses they've like it literally there's literally a
special part like a small part special part in their brain
That's just fully dedicated.
It's called the Pokédex.
We have our...
Yeah, we have our own internal Pokédex in our brains.
No, it was like two days ago.
It was like two to three days.
It was before April Fool's.
I'm pretty sure.
I remember.
Why won't you connect?
Why won't you love each other?
Actually went rent-free.
The self-marketing, the guerrilla marketing tactics actually
worked.
Someone should hire those marketers.
Yeah, these are duds.
Oh yeah, that definitely doesn't connect.
Where are my corner pieces?
Oh, there they are.
Wait, I've done this one before.
Did I?
I can't tell.
They were all blurred together.
They're all corners now.
They're all side pieces.
Have I done this one yet?
Oh yeah, there's no way that connects unless...
Oh!
Yay!
Okay, let's try it.
Oh my god, I'm on a row!
Okay, never mind.
I broke the streak.
Okay, unless...
Uh, this has to be...
Okay, yeah, no, that definitely doesn't fit.
Maybe?
Okay, no.
No.
Oh, it has to be a hole.
Okay, but that was a good streak, though.
I literally got four more pieces in.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, oh, oh!
Okay.
I didn't place it down yet, so that doesn't count.
Oh, I don't have any.
Unlucky.
Wait, maybe I can find it in the pile?
Look, I'm doing it!
I'm doing it!
I've placed it down.
It's technically the streak is still alive.
I just need to find the right piece.
Oh my god, where is it, though?
It's like a little...
I'm not gonna say it.
But we all know what that.
A little what, Toki?
Yeah, yeah, it's like a little nose, exactly.
It's like a little nose, guys.
God.
Oh, my God.
I can't have a fucking genius.
Oh, I broke the streak.
Four in a row.
That was pretty good.
though oh my god it was the other one four oh oh oh my god
wait wait they were all just here lined up together okay we
gotta find another another hole for it this one no it's not
this one where is that hole is this no we
need another hole maybe this one does that hole fit that
hole no maybe this hole not that hole we gotta find the hole
that matches perfectly Try grouping all the white pieces
together.
The white piece goes over here.
And the other white piece.
That's in the group B.
That looks like a group C white piece, doesn't it, guys?
Oh my god, which hole fits that hole?
So many holes.
Let's see.
Maybe this hole?
No.
That's not the right hole.
This one?
Yay!
Alright, and now there's a tiny one right here.
Can we...
Yes, we have Lindsay Tokey again.
Doctor, thank you.
the super chat thank you thank you how badly do you want her
to come back guys yeah no well yeah all right whoever
outfits doctor gets to have no swimsuit dokey
five dollars for swimsuit dokey do we have a five dollars
and one cent for no swimsuit ducky
where the fuck is oh my god i can't seem to find that piece
where is the other corner piece maybe you know i'm gonna try
the other side
no more like trial and error now
no do not bring her back i beg of you solid thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you happy easter from sweden
curling drinking while watching this i'm sure you can fill
all the hoes toky thank you the super chat thank you thank
you top thank you for the super chat thank you thank you isa
thank you with the super chat thank you thank you bring the
cutie back 20 for a Sudoki.
Do we have a $20 and one cent?
Do we...
Yeah, I'm getting lost in the sauce right now.
Trying to find...
Trying to find that one piece.
Please!
No!
WV, thank you for the Magenta Supa, thank you, thank you.
I'm $50 for no swimsuit dokey.
Bring, please, an Akka Supa from Asian.
Thank you for the Akka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Eating, thank you for the super chat.
Bring her back.
All right, an Akka.
All right, let's see.
It's like someone's like, free her and no keeper in there.
I'm fucking...
Where are the other pieces?
Do I have any more side pieces?
What the fuck is this piece?
That is not a jigsaw puzzle piece.
This is some Kingdom Hearts.
shit now.
Like, what the fuck is this?
Is this supposed to be in the middle?
That's a shuriken.
That ain't, that's not a fucking puzzle piece.
Bring her back.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
We have $100.2 cents.
Alright.
At least I'm putting it all like here so I can Try them like
I don't have to refine these goddamn pieces Why not buff a
swimsuit dokey if you want buff swimsuit dokey got one sexy
dokey They're a package deal You can't have one above the
other.
Thank you for the super chat terminator.
Thank you.
Thank you That is not Not fair.
Fuck you.
Never bring her back.
Asia, thank you.
The Akka super thank you.
Thank you.
I don't even know what's that converted to in US dollars.
Can I have someone convert that?
So we know if they outbid or not.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Oh, yay!
Oh, like 200.
Oh.
Probably like five.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I need something that connects and not connects at the
same time.
If that weird thing comes out, I'm leaving.
Don't talk about buff dokey like that.
Just because she has more muscle than you.
oh that's like two dollars okay so it's still 100 so it's
still not it's still at what was it you're just jealous
you're just jealous all right so we're still bringing her
back then we're still at a hundred dollars and one cent all
right at 12 at 105 the decision will be made.
The current decision is bring her back.
I've lost track.
Where was I in this puzzle?
Oh, this, okay.
I need to find this tiny thing.
The tiny hole.
One of these pieces fit.
Is there any more side pieces I'm missing?
There's no way that's all the side pieces.
There has to be more.
It's 200 pieces.
This is not look like 200 pieces and she saw right through
me.
No, if I add a two in there, she'll think it's a really big
number.
there are more side pieces.
I swear to God, I can't find...
Oh, wait, there is one.
Yeah, but that's not the side piece I'm looking for.
Oh, wait.
There's one here.
Okay.
Oh, I mean, hey, I can do this part.
Okay, and then there's a little curve here.
Not that one.
Maybe this.
Okay, I almost got that one.
Oh, there we go.
And then...
No.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I can see it.
I can see the vision in my head.
I think this might be...
I think this puzzle might make, like, a flag or something.
It could be a flag of Japan.
You guys don't know that.
We just got the border.
It could be the flag.
See?
What?
Doki.
Next is do a 3D concert with a swimsuit.
Oh, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All I'm saying is Issa is winning.
It's winning the battle right now.
$100 and one cent to bring her back.
In three minutes, I might actually bring her back.
in three seconds she might actually come back or not three
in three minutes
okay it's none of these pieces I got five more side pieces
oh wait there's this one but I don't think this one yeah
there's no way is this one oh but is this one oh okay What
do you think is this?
No, that's not gonna fit.
No.
Maybe this.
No, I looked at this already.
Look, he paid for the service.
Buy her freedom.
He's literally buying her freedom.
Do not believe in democracy.
Let's see.
Oh, one more minute, guys.
One more minute, and she's coming back.
The auction is about to close.
It's going to close in a minute.
Her bell is about to be posted, guys.
That's lobby.
Keep it in the basement And coming in with a steel chair
Solid Snake The snipe from downtown Mr. Broken Bond Keep it
in the basement Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa I know the
And Solid Snake Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa I know the
basement is a CQC Don't bring her back Take her behind the
farm
The bill has been raised to like $200 and something dollars
Matt, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you The
bill has been raised I'm sorry sexy dokey You just can't
handle how sexy you You are just too sexy for this world The
gate has been locked.
She won't be let out today.
They just can't handle your sexiness.
One day.
One day the world will be ready.
Thank God this is just extortion.
The internet was just not ready.
She was too ahead of her time.
Thank God.
There's no way.
There has to be more side pieces.
I think I got them all.
Okay.
We just gotta figure out which goes into what.
Yeah.
Obviously not this.
That one doesn't curve up.
It can't be any pieces I have right now.
None of them fit.
Oh, unless...
It's not that.
Okay.
What the fuck is this piece then?
Oh!
Alright, now we just gotta figure out...
Alright, they're all like...
It's all like, uh, flipped like this now.
You know?
no
maybe this one okay nice okay i'm starting to recognize the
circles the circular circular shape and where it's supposed
to go like i was like yeah that that's the circle yeah you
fit in that hole see oh my god i'm so good at this i'm
an expert circle detector I mean, none of these look like...
Oh, wait, unless it's this.
Okay, no.
Has to be this one.
It's not?
Oh, wait, it's this one.
There we go.
A true filler of holes.
Okay.
Is this one?
No.
Oh, hey, okay, that works, too.
Oh, I mean...
I mean, if it fits, it fits.
Alright, I am missing some circles.
Okay, yeah, I was going to say that that looks like that
fits.
Alright, we are missing some piece.
Oh, there it is.
What the fuck is this piece in my...
Oh, it's this.
I'm still a little confused, but...
If it works, it works.
Okay.
Alright, it's like that.
And then...
Alright, we're missing one last side piece.
It's in here somewhere.
I think I can... I think I know what this puzzle is, guys.
I think I can figure out the picture of this soon.
Thank God this is a digital puzzle, not a real puzzle.
Because I've had... I hate when you, like, lose one puzzle
piece or two puzzle piece.
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
it okay now now I don't fucking know what to do this is
where things get a little tricky oh no okay this is where I
this is where I'm a little afraid time time for the fun part
of this puzzle like the hard part is that it can be any side
it really
Oh my god, it really can't be any of them.
Wait, it's harder than I thought.
Wait a minute.
This is that.
Wait a fucking minute.
Oh shit.
Wait, I'm my sub- wait.
I didn't think this through.
I might not have to.
thought this through okay all right i have a plan i have a
plan there must be more weird-ass shaped puzzles pieces
somewhere look at i'll just get the weird shit ones the
weird ones
oh it could be any corner really could be any fucking corner
oh no how do i even how do i even get started on this I have
made a horrible mistake I don't even know where to start
okay all right we'll do trial and error somewhere the trial
will makes sense
okay obviously it's not any of these holes
oh no i've really made a mistake i
i'm i've never been so confused before wait that has to fit
oh my god wait a minute okay we found one of the weird
shapes okay one of these weird shapes fit into that weird
shape
okay okay okay it's this we got five more leaves
congratulations on your first 24 hours thank you for the
super chat with nard with nardro thank you thank you i can
do guys we just got fun There's so many weird shaped puzzle
pieces You're just gonna find one of those leaves One of
these leaves will fit in that hole Okay Why are there so
many of them
Guys it's only 20 200 pieces guys It's not surely it can't
be that Oh my god okay we found one of the weird leaves
Okay, now there's this weird leaf.
Is there another weird leaf shape?
That was the only one.
I don't know what else to do now.
I...
Wait, there's another weird leaf shape.
Oh my god, wait.
There's another one.
Okay, we'll put it in this corner.
Don't worry, guys.
We just gotta find another...
There's another weird leaf shape here.
surely one of the weird leaves will fit into that weird leaf
I'm just trying everything I'm not even like oh this doesn't
look like that shape I'm just like if it's a weird fucking
leaf I'm gonna try it
yeah that leaf is a little too skinny that one too there's
more here we're gonna do this one weird leaf shape at a
time.
Yeah.
Is there any more?
There has to be.
There was always more.
That's too skinny.
Is there any more weird leaves?
All right.
Let's put that here.
Oh!
Where did he...
Wait, what?
Oh my.
I got it.
Oh my god.
It's right here.
I'm I take those.
I fucking take those.
I was like, what the fuck?
What clicked?
Anymore weirdly.
There's so many.
And they're all like, they all fit the corner.
Yeah, that's right.
That's fine.
skill right there I'm gonna run out of weird-ass leaves soon
surely right surely I run out of weird fucking leave-shaped
puzzle pieces there's
more oh my god it's like this puzzle is like 200 pieces or
some shit just never ends there's another one is there more
any more weird leaves guys there has to be more because
nothing is fitting in that space how
much to turn off guys i i do want to end stream eventually
okay i still have some weird ass leaves oh my god okay back
to the leaves again
back to trial and error
okay one of these will fit
it's a big leaf it is
okay these are skinny leaves still doesn't hurt to try maybe
they expand maybe they expand at when it gets too hot
they're like whoa there's so many of you there's i'm so
nervous and then the leaf starts expanding
oh nice okay i'll put this in this corner now
That's where it clicked.
Okay, we figured it out.
It attached to one of the leaves.
The leaves found each other.
Wait.
This might have been a bad idea.
I should have got a picture.
I...
I went straight to zero.
What?
Okay, something clicked in there.
I went to zero to 100 real quick.
I could have started small.
I mean, like, completely...
a puzzle instead i went like complete a solid color puzzle
and then you want to do easier medium harder hell mode i was
like i was like i want to be in the ninth circle of hell
yeah i was just like oh man i wish it was a thousand pieces
200 seems too easy
pastor he was so hopeful he was like i've done puzzle before
that were that had pictures on them but a puzzle is still a
puzzle it's like i've never done a solid color puzzle before
but how hard can it be every puzzle has a solution aphelion
thank you for the five gifted ships thank you thank you need
more leaves wait this must be it I thought that was it.
It was a thick leaf.
That leaf was so thick, too.
These are skinny-ass leaves.
Professor?
Any more leaf puzzle pieces?
This one?
No?
Definitely not that one.
I swear I found every fucking leaf puzzle pieces.
Are there any Do you guys see any more?
Okay, there is this one, but this one's too skinny.
That one's not gonna fit.
Maybe this?
Nah.
Then here, a thousand piece puzzle next.
Let's go.
Good job.
Thank you for the way to Super Chat.
Thank you.
No, I knew that one was too skinny.
Where are the thick ones?
This one, maybe?
No.
I think that's all.
Oh, wait, no.
There's this one, too.
Yeah, no, that's definitely not gonna fit.
Actually, no more?
Far left.
Yeah, but that doesn't look like...
Yeah, that doesn't look like it fit.
See?
I could tell.
That fuck up?
It must have been one that fit, and I was just like...
And I just didn't try it or something.
shit no that's definitely too skinny oh maybe this one oh
there we go all right back to trial and error
okay obviously it's none of these
yeah yeah at this point i don't even need a click on it i
just gotta there you go Okay, and that's a skinny leaf.
Okay, skinny leaves.
No, not skinny enough.
Oh, unless...
No, that's not it.
And I'm going a lot faster than I expect to.
I think now...
This is where it gets a little harder.
Right down there.
We'll have to do the next...
What the...
At the next side.
At least I know that.
Which one fit and which doesn't.
Like I don't even bother to try to piece it together.
Oh.
There you go.
Okay.
And then a thick one.
None.
No.
I still.
This one I don't understand.
This is a kid.
Kingdom Hearts shit right here.
You know, I just realized Kingdom Hearts has been around
for, like, more than... How many years?
20 plus years or some shit?
Okay, now I don't know.
Now I think I'm in the corner.
Now I'm just confused.
I guess these, right?
That's to be one of these.
A 24 years right I heard there was like a special kingdom
hearts event um like a fan event it's gonna be like the last
one the last one ever organized it's like what was it it's
like that my little pony one where they're like uh this is
the last my little pony convention ever and then they're
like this is the last kingdom hearts convention ever now
apparently like a really well-known uh Kingdom Hearts fan
convention is ending this year.
Because they're like, oh, we're like, we got, we're adult,
we got to move on.
They're just like, yeah, like, we're just going to let the
new generation organize this.
We got to move on with our lives.
Yeah, because they've grown up.
Maybe they have like kids now.
And they're like, I'm sorry, guys.
We can't organize another Kingdom Hearts convention.
We gotta save money.
And spend time with the kids.
Which is pretty.
You know.
Pretty wholesome.
Being like.
You know.
Oh yeah I heard about the bar.
Okay now I'm in trouble.
There's no more funny leaves now.
Guys.
There's no more funny leaves shapes.
What do I do now?
out none of these look like funny shapes no more like but
yes no i have i've heard about the the barbie convention
which was like a spiritual successor to that was it the the
tumblr convention was a dashcom okay now now i'm actually
confused maybe it's this way maybe could be this looks like
this might make another funny leaf shape maybe
i'm betting on the side this looks like a side piece
unless you're all like here oh wait no this looks like this
also looks like a piece that can go to the side all right
all in on side piece
Come on, it has to be one of these.
It's not that one.
Tom, thank you for five gift and ships.
Thank you.
Oh my god, I've been doing this puzzle so long.
The public domain free music for my free game has finally
stopped.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
It's back.
It looped back.
They're like, you're still here?
You're still not done with your fucking puzzle?
It's back.
They thought I would be finished by now.
They were not ready to loop the music.
No, not that one.
Oh my god.
I'm having a feeling that it's not a side piece anymore.
There is no way it's none of these.
Yeah, I knew it wasn't that one.
It's not the right shape.
Oh my god, how many fucking side pieces are there?
It's like...
It's like 200 pieces.
It's like almost as if there's 200 pieces or some shit.
It has to be a side piece.
For all of them here.
All the side pieces out.
Alright, that has...
That's all of them.
If it's none of these, then it can't be a side piece.
I just need to know if it isn't a long oh my god it's not a
side wait unless no it fits it fits perfectly in a lot okay
there's my side piece corner right here
I'm starting to feel it's not a side piece guys I'm I'm
starting to get a feeling
I don't know Alright, it was not Unfortunately it was not
Alright Now what, that was my entire plan What do I do now?
Okay, maybe Maybe it's a long piece Okay We go again But
this time is long piece hours
Okay, no We just need to get one line started And then it's
all Gucci Okay And then we figured it out.
We just need one line.
It could be a long piece.
Because it makes the silly leaves.
Oh my god.
This actually almost fits perfectly.
You can't.
There's no way.
The moment I figured this line up.
It's all over.
Everything will come together.
And then we can figure out what this puzzle.
What picture this puzzle makes.
Oh my god.
you guys see the newest overwatch drama um it was apparently
an overwatch org that wasn't paying players and then like
what are the it like showed on my on my timeline uh
basically one of the org wasn't playing i mean which is like
i i'm not surprised like there's always it's always
something like that regarding orgs esport orgs in general
because like like i said owning i feel like esport orgs are
just like barely a positive in like profits in general it's
really hard for any esport org to make money um apparently
uh an overwatch esport org wasn't paying well not well they
don't just do overwatch but they do other stuff was it
wasn't like paying their like staff and players or just like
really really late payment and i read the google doc and i
thought it was so um that was sent and he was like hey man
so like because basically this guy knew it i fucking knew it
all right it's leaf time and i'm sorry and then um he was
like hey man so like what am i gonna oh my god what corner
do i put this in i'll put it here when am i i'm well hey man
i still haven't been paid yet and he was like sorry i didn't
pay you i was sad
i was too Sad.
And I was just like, what the fuck do you mean?
It's like the CEO literally was like, I was sad.
Sorry, dude, I didn't pay you yet.
I'm like, what the fuck?
I was just like, he's sad.
He was too sad to pay.
A fucking staff member he employed.
Like, yeah, that was the CEO, by the way.
I was, I was too sad.
like the irs hates this one trick to say you're sad and
you're like oh i understand i i wish i could tell that to my
bills i'm just just depressed man i get sorry buddy it's the
wild the most wild of all everything in that google dockey i
don't know it's just and then like it was typed in the way
where it was like a bit cringe too like
but yeah anyway that's just basically the new drama
everyone's like what the was just like oh wait wait you
weren't getting paid either and then basically like one guy
made a google dockey about it Uh, and then, like, everyone
else, and then the other ex-staff, uh, or, like, past
players were like, wait a minute, you also weren't getting
paid?
And then, and then it was too late.
It, it, like, opened a floodgate.
And then everyone made their own little Google Dockey and
tweet about it.
And I, I, personally, I don't know.
I would be very surprised if the org stays alive after that.
I'd be very surprised Because it's like, you know, after
like one time It's really hard to regain trust after that,
you know After you get exposed Like after an or Especially
like an org or something gets exposed It's hard to regain
trust Oh my god, my freaky leaf ship There has to be an
easier way for this Yes, Stokey There is an easier way If
there was a picture at it for it could be easier but where's
the challenge in that though
where is the challenge guys
oh my god i'm fucking i'm in the thing is i'm stuck in my
the hell i built
oh okay well something clicked i'll take that I take those.
I heard a click.
I built this cage.
And then I threw away the key.
It's none of these?
There's no way.
It's none of them.
Okay, I swear to God.
I was like, if this is, if it's the last piece I put on it,
I swear to God.
It was actually none of them.
Oh my God.
Am I missing a leaf?
Oh, I might be.
You're under other leaves in here?
Wait, there are these leaves.
I don't think they're the same type of leaves, though.
Yeah, they don't look like the same type of leaves that I'm
trying to find.
Did I lose a piece?
Quick, everyone!
Look under your desk!
It might have fallen down there.
Oh my god, have I been clicking too fast that I forgot to
place one that should could have been the leaf?
Did daddy oh my god.
I've tried all the pieces.
I don't oh my god Okay, okay, that's fine We'll do this it
could be this this part might be easier
Yeah try again.
Well, it's time to try again, don't you.
Okay, it has to be one of these thick pieces for this.
It's not?
What do you mean it's not?
What the fuck do you mean?
Oh my god.
What got 50 pieces that?
What got fucking puzzle pieces?
am i looking at it it's fine oh my god i don't know if it's
like how the fuck does this work
why would what oh
my i just i just don't know i i just don't know i i i don't
know i don't
even know what piece will connect to this what fucking god
damn monstrosity does this connect to
okay i don't know i don't even know where to start anymore i
any of them
guys this is no lot for some reason i don't feel relaxed
anymore
I don't feel relaxed anymore for some reason.
Like, I don't even know what shape to use.
Okay, leaves.
Where's my leaf pile?
Alright, we're gonna start from the beginning.
We're gonna... This is the only clue I have.
It's a leaf.
Alright, my leaf pile.
Truly one of the leaves will fit.
You picked this game.
I underestimated.
I might have...
No, no.
I might have overestimated my skills and puzzles.
I might have been a little too overconfident in myself.
Just a little bit.
I was like, how hard can it be?
It's a fucking puzzle.
I like how I just hear rats.
of clicks in the fucking pile so you did it and i was like
what did i do
check alive cat the actors a solution posted is it is it
just a is it just a white image is that the solution guys
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
I think I should have, like, had a progression on, like,
these puzzles.
I should have started with an actual picture.
Guys, if I started with an actual picture, then the stream
would have ended in, like, 10 minutes, guys.
You're not... You just...
I had a feeling that was the solution.
Guys, you don't know yet.
It could be anything.
It could be snow.
It could be a flag of Japan.
We don't know what it looks like in the center yet, guys.
Yeah, it could be winter in Canada.
It could be anything.
Oh my god, it's none of these leaves.
Oh my god, I figured it.
It's actually none of these leaves.
I don't have any more leaves.
What other leaf is there?
There's no more leaves in here.
I've tried all the leaves.
What other leaf could be in this corner?
Oh my god, I forgot to rotate one of the leaves.
Oh my god, I forgot to rotate.
rotate the leaves okay we'll try again
are these all side pieces maybe i left the leaf in there
maybe i i'm starting to cope maybe there's a leaf in this
pile maybe
which one have i not rotated i can't tell
oh my god there are leaves i haven't rotated yet
Oh my god!
We did it.
We fucking did it.
We got him.
Okay, that has to be a thick boy.
That has to be a thick boy right here.
But which thick boy is it?
Okay, not this one.
Okay, it's one where it's like slightly curved.
To the right.
Is it not any of these thick boys?
It's none of the thick boys.
That's all the thick boys I have.
Yeah, this is my thick boy pile.
It's like slightly curved to the right.
All my thick boys.
Oops, all these.
I can't rotate these.
It's a leaf.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it could be.
It could be one of these that attach themselves.
quickly okay why is the side pieces here oh my god you're
right it could be the leaves
oh my god it could be a leaf a puzzles with dokey bird okay
no oh i mean i'll take it i'll take it any random click oh
my god it could be the fucked up ones too
okay It's not this.
I'm just happy that random puzzle pieces are clicking
together for me.
Okay, not these.
Nope.
Oh, there you go.
All right.
More leaves.
More.
Okay, wait, no.
What the fuck is that?
Is that side piece?
That has to be a side piece, right?
Yeah.
That's a long boy.
Okay.
Looks like a long boy.
I think?
It's a long boy into it.
And the next one is a leaf piece.
We're starting to run out of leaf pieces.
So that's good news.
That's good news for us.
Yeah, guys.
It could be a smile.
face in the end.
Okay, that's easier.
Just doing a little break dance in the middle of this.
Could be any of any one of them.
Guys, the little the corner pieces was definitely the
easiest part about the entire puzzle.
I was like, wow, this is so easy, guys.
This is...
Oh, poor Naive Doki.
When I started, I was like, wow, guys.
This is so easy.
I figured out the holes.
Guys, I'm starting to believe it's not the side pieces.
I'm starting to think it's not any of these.
Okay.
Well, now we know.
It's none of them.
Which one is it?
What piece could it be?
Is it the... Oh my god, I swear to god.
Don't tell me it's another leaf.
Oh my god!
No, it can't be.
I'm so tired.
Oh!
I don't know!
Oh man, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
The spring bat memories we thought fatly, fast, slow, and
trying each was a good eye.
I don't know!
Where do they go?
Wait, this has to be a long boy, right?
Or is it a thick boy?
I don't know.
Where do they go?
Maybe I'll find a solution if I keep flipping.
If I keep flipping.
oh no okay this has to be a lot of my mother's mini-present
she taught your method is upsetting Ellie thank you for this
super chat thank you thank you what other method can I do
it's just all white what Where do any of these shapes go?
I don't know.
I don't even know what shape makes white.
I can't tell.
Into the void.
Like, it's not the big boys.
to god is it the leaves oh my god or is it the leaves again
it's
not the leaves
i can't i'm so tired of looking at this picture i'm already
so tired of looking at it it's only been an hour and i'm
like why doesn't this end
yeah is it the leaf okay could be the leaf i'll put it in
the leaf corner again could be a leaf on the side
okay it could be a side leaf
i wish there were more when i was on this side it was so
easy and then quick run out of spice you try not to stop the
puzzle while i'm god god thank you this super chat thank you
thank you
like what piece goes in there
okay we got five all right i got an idea okay i'm gonna have
two groups all right we gotta find the one that curves to
like that you see that i can i can see that okay all right i
have a plan
okay that one doesn't curve the one that curves to the right
that's the plan the moment we find the curved the curved
circular thing We'll find the answer.
It's only 200 pieces.
How bad can it be?
Okay.
None of these curve.
Just slightly curved to the right.
Okay, none of these curve.
Okay.
We're going by curvedness now.
That is my category.
polarization
Just it just if if the puzzle piece is slightly curved we'll
try it will try and see if it fits in the fucking hole Yeah,
I mixed it all together.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, I mixed all the leaves
together.
It's a little fucked
We've made a little oopsie all the leaves are now mixed
together.
I don't know where the other leaves are.
Guys, the curve system works.
Guys, you all doubted the curve system.
We'll find a way.
All right, thank you, a super chap.
Thank you, thank you.
I had a weird dream that you were being wearing a bikini.
Thank God.
It was just a dream.
Thank you for the safer chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, just a weird dream.
Yeah, definitely.
Okay.
We found the system.
Alright, one down.
Oh!
Okay, this is another leaf shape.
Alright, we'll put this one here.
The leaf palette.
is back, baby.
Never left.
Are you being forced to complete this puzzle?
Help.
Play twice if you need help.
I am thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
I just got a little overconfident with my puzzle skills.
I was like, ah, doing a, that's so easy.
I've done puzzles my whole young life.
Surely it won't go too bad.
never did a solid puzzle before but it can't be that hard
it's all digital too all right what the fuck is this corner
here i don't know i hold that thing give this super chat i
am making progress what do you mean
being made right now okay that has to be a long piece yeah
all right this okay this one is a little harder for oh all
right all right never mind never mind no way
to the circle there we go okay okay it's actually working
out right now
okay it's back to the circle
okay we're at the third line now it gets easier guys this
gets easier again don't worry
I'm in the zone now I'm in the I got into the flow state
Okay It has to Okay leave coroner Okay we'll put the leaves
We're gonna Oh fuck Okay here That's those are lines too It
has to be a line
Oh my It has to be a line It's just no other puzzle piece
it's like it's so long oh my god it has to be one of them
i missed my leaf system guys it was so much simpler i just
gotta find the leaf
oh oh okay i knew that wouldn't fit i was like wait a minute
that should fit okay now that has to be a leaf right here
that's that's a leaf okay well it has to be right that's
where the leaves go okay that's
where all the leaves go to die all right that should have
actually fit though
yeah it is a leaf shape fucking knew it
The leaf has to be in that corner.
Okay, are there any more leaves?
Okay.
These are my funky shaped ones.
I mean, they sort of work, too.
No, they don't.
Alright.
This actually makes it a lot harder for me.
The ones that clicked.
Okay, it's none of these.
No.
Oh my god.
God, which one is it?
Hey.
Oh, come on.
That one fucking...
Come on.
It's just a little hole.
Just a little guy.
Are you serious?
It's like three pieces that look like it's gonna fit.
Uh...
Oh my God, friend.
I'm running out.
I'm running out of leaves.
It was none of them.
I don't understand.
What do you mean?
Oh, wait, there's more.
I have more.
It's okay.
I have more pals.
Apparently, I have a bigger pal.
Leave pals than I thought I did.
Pal was a lot bigger than I thought.
Oh, my God.
It doesn't get easier.
I think he'll get easier.
easier.
But it doesn't get easier, guys.
It doesn't get easier.
Oh, every time, every time we touch, I get this feeling
because every time.
That's how I feel right now.
That's how Man, what a great stream for the color of life.
This yellow puzzle looks amazing.
Dr. Crabberry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Because every time we touch, I get the ceilings.
Every time we pop.
I'm just losing.
I'm fucking losing it.
There's so many pieces.
pieces.
I thought it'll get easier.
She had to pay for April for the sins.
Alan, thank you for answering for chat.
Thank you.
It doesn't get easier.
They lied.
I don't know what to do anymore.
Where do these pieces go?
Okay.
All right.
I don't know.
I've made so many piles.
My leaf piles.
There's so many leaves.
This is just all leaves.
Oh.
I get hearing the clicks.
At least the leaves are connecting to each other.
At least they're having a fun time.
Does this go down?
okay we'll do we'll do the curve theory again
okay you
know as long if it's curved to the right this might be the
one it may just throw everything in the pile true anarchy do
it toky chuck it all in that pile and then what am I gonna
do with it they're all still white puzzles what am I gonna
do with the pile after where's plan B where's step 2 are you
fucking kidding me this doesn't connect
the fucking strategy throw it in the other pile and then
maybe something and then it'll click again
oh my god it was literally the last piece of fucking course
it was the last piece
I don't know if it's cert if it's I just don't know what
piece he's making slightly smaller files
and then just keep making pal some more things click
like i don't is this a side piece again it must be a side
piece right i think so okay circle theory
okay you mean it the it's pointing straight that's my circle
theory if it put I gotta find the ones that point straight
and that's the game theory is there's some that leans to the
left and lean to the right and I'm trying to find the one
that points straight
see look This one leans a little to the right.
I think it's a leaf.
I'm pretty sure it is.
Oh, never mind.
JK, JK.
It has to be a thick...
This one has to be a thick boy.
Okay, and it has to lean.
Okay, I don't think so anymore.
I don't have any that leans to the right.
Do I?
No.
yeah none of them lean to the right okay we gotta find wait
don't tell me it's another side there's no way it's yeah
it's not another side it's a leaf it's a leaf piece wait
unless actually i can't tell i can't tell i can't tell no
more what piece is it It's a leaf piece.
It's a leaf piece.
Okay, we gotta find the one that leans to the right.
My circle theory.
Okay.
This has been the most efficient theory so far.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, no.
No.
Yeah.
There's so many.
Why are there so many leaves?
I came back from the store and you still have it.
You do it.
You try it.
How about we both do a 200 piece puzzle together and see who
finished first?
Like,
Let's have a little race then.
All right.
What is this?
This has to be.
Okay.
Now.
Oh my god.
Please don't tell me it's another leaf.
It's another leaf.
Wait unless...
No, it's another leaf.
Only 106 pieces left, Toki!
My personal hell.
I locked myself up in this.
That it was my choice.
Okay, it's like a little pinched at the top.
So it's like a little pimple.
There we go.
Okay, now it's...
piece time okay it leans oh my god wait this theory is has
actually been like it's actually working guys it works oh my
god okay all right this is a tiny one Leans slightly to the
right.
Oh, I'm actually doing it.
I'm actually doing it.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It's working.
I don't know how, but it's...
Okay, now I don't know which one.
Which piece is this?
Could be a long one.
This one leans.
Yes, I knew it.
All right.
It's another long piece or a leaf piece.
Fuck.
I don't get anything.
It's working.
It's like working.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Is Tuesday this is a long piece or a leaf piece?
Chat.
Which one are my piles?
Which one?
I can't tell.
I still have so many leaf pieces.
Well, I don't know.
The leaf?
I can't tell.
I don't know if this is leaf or not.
If it was...
Okay, this is...
If it was leaf, it has to be like...
Oh.
I don't know.
This makes another leaf.
Okay.
If they have two colors.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, patch.
It's a leaf?
I can't tell for this.
It has to be like...
Okay.
If it's a leaf, then it has to lean a little to the left or
right, technically.
Okay, no.
Okay, it's like the leaning tower pizza.
Oh, okay.
Every time.
See, Toki, the palestrat works.
Yeah.
I think it's...
I have a feeling it's not the leaf right now.
I can't find the one that leans a little to the right.
They all lean.
They all lean down instead of up.
Okay, that's down.
Oh, oh.
Oh, that was the only one that leaned it.
Leaned up.
Okay.
All right, then it has to be...
Okay, it has to be this then.
It has to lean up.
Oh, fuck, it was the long one.
Okay.
All right, that has to be...
That has to be a long boy.
Right?
Yeah, that has to be a long boy.
Oh my god, I'm getting into my second flow state.
My second wind flow state.
It's hitting me guys.
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
Which one is this?
Leaf?
or side chat leaf or side what do you guys think
is this a leaf or a side looks like a leaf are these also
leaf pieces if it's a leaf it has to go like this it has to
be like a super skinny hole I'm looking at holes now the
hole theory my new theory
okay one day I'll know where this goes
it can't be anything else right it has to be this side oh
yeah all right
the hole is the goal
okay no oh
god damn it
Where is the curve?
Oh, wait, this one.
God damn it.
Maybe this?
No!
It has to be like, oh, I must have fucked up.
I always go in trial and error this.
Oh, never mind.
Okay, I'll take it.
I'll take those.
I take those.
Okay, now I'll figure out.
This has to be...
One of the lines, right?
Okay, we're going to go with the hole theory now.
Just looking at the holes.
One brick at a time.
We are making piles, guys.
Maybe something will click.
Really, that should click right here.
Okay, maybe the hole theory doesn't work.
Or is it a leaf?
No, it's not a leaf.
There's no way that's the leaf hole.
Wait, unless?
Nothing makes sense!
I don't understand anymore!
None of this make any sense!
I thought I was so clever!
With all my fingers!
theories but that's all they are a fucking theory nothing
makes sense in this world what am I doing okay
another one done okay it's like a little pimple shape.
It should be like one of these.
It's not one of these.
It has to be a leaf then.
Right?
It has to be a leaf.
Oh, it's definitely a leaf.
Okay, it's similar to that shape.
Like a little pinched there.
Where the fuck is the little pinch?
Oh my god, I've been doing for two hours.
I...
It doesn't even feel like two hours.
What has my life become?
It's all I am.
Just a silly person doing a puzzle.
Just try to live, get through life.
Are you glad you didn't do a thousand pieces?
I didn't think it would be so hard.
This is my life.
This is my punishment for all the crimes I've committed.
My own purgatory.
My fucking puzzle purgatory.
It's not a long boy.
Oh.
Can't be a long boy.
Wait, what kind of boy is this?
Oh my god, is it a leaf?
Is it a goddamn fucking leaf?
Oh my god, it's a fucking leaf, isn't it?
I actually, no, it's just spreading the pieces.
Wait, I could sort, okay, no, I, no, I don't, I don't need
to do that.
I'm better than that.
I am better than that.
Where the fuck is the curve?
My curve theory.
None of them curve!
Oh Stella
They're all just fucking blocks
Oh my god, where do they go?
Where do these fucking pieces connect?
Oh my there we go.
There we go.
We figured it out.
We figured it out Put these guys back in this pile my leaf
pile I gotta slowly move them.
Okay.
I gotta slowly move them, so I have more space.
There's so many leaf pieces.
It doesn't stop.
I'm still moving them.
Okay, it's fine.
This has to be a long piece.
Okay, curve theory time.
Okay, wait, what?
That was a new click.
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god, I did it.
Oh, dear.
I found the one piece.
Just kept stacking until it worked.
Where are these pieces?
And none of them curve.
I don't understand.
What?
Oh my god, it's because It was a fat piece.
Okay.
All right.
Leaf time.
Okay.
This has to be an easy one.
It's just a leaf.
There's so many of them, though.
There's so many of them.
My God, please.
One of these leaves will fit.
One of them will fit.
Just fit.
Okay.
Please!
Get in there!
This hole was literally made for you!
Where else would you go?
Oh, there you go.
Yay!
Okay.
Oh my god, the double.
Oh, baby, a double!
Oh, oh, oh, wait, I think!
Okay, that's not the leaf I was looking for.
It was almost there.
It's not the leaf you were looking for, Luke.
It has to curve up.
It's gotta curve up.
Not this one.
It's not the leaf.
long oh unless oh it is all right leaf leaf time i can see
it's almost there
we're almost halfway we're almost halfway we're getting rid
of the leaf pieces i can see it the leaves it's finally
gonna end.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
We can piece this one.
It's just leaves.
I've lost track of where my groups are.
I've lost track.
I don't know what pile is what anymore.
Other than my fucking leaf pile.
Yeah.
My Fucking leaf pile.
See you.
It's all I have.
Oh my god.
Something fit in there.
Oh shit.
Another thing fit together.
The pile strikes again.
Just keep putting shit in the pile.
Eventually something will fit.
okay there we go oh my god is that another leaf yes sirree
okay thank god thank god for leaves
oh my god oh baby a double oh fucking baby a double all
right this has to be a long It has to be.
It's not curved, so.
It's not that.
Wait, what could it be?
Oh, please don't tell me it's another league.
No!
No, it can't be.
It can't be.
It could be this.
No, it's not.
Oh my god, no, it can't be a leaf, no.
No, no.
Why is it always?
Oops, all these.
It has to be this way, but it's a leaf.
Oh my god.
My arm's getting tight.
I think I was actually getting tired.
I've been rotating puzzle pieces all day.
So much leaflet.
Why do you hate your country ventoki?
Only thank you for the super chat.
What do you mean?
99 pieces to go.
It doesn't get easier.
It doesn't get easy.
It actually doesn't get easier.
Please.
What have I done these?
Wait, this, I have it on this.
Oh!
Oh my god, it wasn't a leaf.
It was a leaf.
Oh, Okay, but this is a leaf, though.
Oh, back to the leaves.
I've never clicked my mouse so many times before.
I just click click click click click click click click click
click click click click click click rotate click click piece
rotate oh whoops something piece together in there
whoa someone found their perfect match
oh oh
I'm so happy
It's a tiny hole.
Tiny hole theory.
Tiny hole theory, time.
I think it's a leaf.
I think it's a leaf, guys.
No.
Wait, I can do this, though.
What?
Is there anything that leaves?
Nope, it's none of those.
Wait, then, is that...
Is that a leaf?
I have to leave.
Okay, the hole has to lean slightly to the right.
Oh.
Not this one.
There we go.
We found the other leaf.
Found him.
Okay.
Good news is that I am running out of long pieces.
So it's like, bad news is that I don't see a diminishing
amount of leaf pieces.
It feels like it's never ending.
I feel like it's never gonna stop.
Every piece I put, they give me like 20 more leaf pieces to
go through.
You know what, so you enjoy this lovely puzzle after that
April Fool's Drink makes me feel a lot better.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't even give fun facts no more.
It's no longer fun.
I no longer feel the whimsy.
I don't know.
I just don't know.
oh my god i don't know i don't know where did they go
why won't you fit why doesn't anything fit in my life
why doesn't anything fit
you fit i don't understand it's a leaf piece it was a
fucking leaf piece
oh my god i don't even know where that's supposed to go i'm
just eventually something will fit i'm just i'm just gonna
i'm not even gonna think about it like something will fit in
that pile if i just keep sticking it in
I just need one piece.
Just one piece.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You chose to suffer and therefore you sounded like Kamiyoshi
is a massive kiss.
Why is the pile not getting small?
oh my god it doesn't even matter it doesn't even matter i
still need to figure out where it goes what do you mean this
doesn't fit
where the fuck oh my god
i feel like i don't see an ending like i feel like i'm gonna
be trapped here for the rest of my life and then you'll be
trapped here with me
we don't leave until we finish this puzzle
you're here forever in my own design purgatory
It's none of these.
It's none of them.
What do you mean it's none of them?
I put every puzzle piece in.
Oh, it's this one.
Back to the leaves.
Wait, I put this here.
Okay, wait, it could be...
Okay, this could be a long piece, though.
this might be a long piece because this is a leaf piece so
hypothetically speaking if my theory is correct I fucking
knew it and then back to lot back to leaf piece hell back to
the leaf pieces I go okay
None of these.
Or these.
Okay.
Okay, it was this.
Okay, now we have a problem.
Now we have a problem.
Where do I even go from here?
I don't even know.
Because this could be a leaf piece.
Or not?
I don't know.
It could be a long...
Okay, I think it's a long piece.
Okay, we'll test our long pieces first.
That's where we go.
Because we have less long pieces.
Than leaf pieces.
So, by testing this theory out.
a limb we know it has to be a leaf then what if it's a long
leaf don't say don't say such a bullshit in front of me what
the do you mean long leaf piece what do you mean this is a
serious business here this is a serious stream okay that
should have fit though i will have to say that's bullshit i
don't know i don't know i'm so tired of looking at this i'm
so i'm so tired
this is not a joking matter guys we gotta we gotta figure
this out okay these are all the leaf pieces them all okay
something clicked that's good
Maybe don't click again.
The clicky click pile.
Oh my god.
These are all just leaves.
Every single one of them.
Guys, I don't think this is a flag of Japan anymore.
I have a feeling that's not what the picture is in this
puzzle.
Yeah, where's the red?
Yeah, I legitimately thought this would fit, though.
It looked like it could fit perfectly, but I guess I'm
wrong.
I guess I'm wrong.
Maybe if I do it like this, it would fit somewhere over the
rainbow.
Bluebird sing.
Dada, da da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da,
da, da, da, da, da, da, Aaaaaa!
Why don't you just put the side pieces into the pile of long
pieces?
Okay.
That's a wild idea.
I'm I have a theory I'm gonna use my theory again the the
circle theory yeah we're up I'm trying it's like tiny you
see how tiny that is
okay none of these fit but it might fit this one
no no
I'm just gonna see if I can get rid of of the long the the
side pieces here
oh my god all right leaf time we did it boys we found the
leaf okay we found a leaf guys now it's just trial and error
which was half of this puzzle
okay I
will click eventually.
It's gonna start clicking.
We're running out of leaves.
Oh, we're running out.
Oh my god, no.
What do you mean?
That's perfect!
It's just the same color anyway!
Oh my god, there you go.
We got two for...
Okay, we got a two for...
We got a two for one deal.
Ah!
Alright.
Okay.
Let's start with these first.
Alright.
Oh my god, please don't be another leaf.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
All right, now we're at the leaf stage here.
Yeah, I'm just going to put all of these over here.
More leaves.
The less leaves, the easier it gets, guys.
Oh my god, the good.
That's fine by me.
Just keep getting into that pile.
You'll eventually find your soulmate.
Keep trying.
Yeah.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
I'm running out of leaves, guys.
Oh, no.
Please let me that fits.
Oh, what did I do wrong?
Oh, my God.
I know you're in there.
Why don't you fit?
It's in the file.
Oh, okay, whatever.
I mean, it found its soulmate.
It's the white one, Doki.
You missed it.
It's over there.
It's that white piece over there.
Oh, my God.
Forgot to rotate.
that.
It's okay.
I found it.
You found his soulmate.
It's all right.
As long as he found his soulmate.
Okay.
It's back to the leaves.
It's okay.
We're there.
We're almost there.
I could... The pile, guys, the pile, it's getting smaller.
The pile is actually...
getting smaller.
I can see it.
Oh, Joe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Wait.
There's just all leaves.
Wait, guys.
It's just...
There's two leaves.
It's back-to-back leaves.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
The leaf pile.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
I'll get rid of this too.
Oh, come on.
It has to be one of you.
Please, I'm running out of leaves.
I'm running out of leaves.
Oh, no!
I accidentally put them together.
I was gonna say, I forgot to rotate them.
No, I didn't.
Oh, I, I, okay, we got one of the leaves out of the way.
Okay, oh my god, there's another leaf.
Did you ask for another?
Another leaf?
Yeah.
Don't worry, and I'm throwing it into the pile.
So maybe they'll find each other.
Not here.
I'm officially halfway.
I'm officially halfway, guys.
I can see it.
I see the light is calling for me.
For some reason, the light is in front of me and it's
calling for me.
I see it, guys.
I actually see it.
It's shining.
Okay.
I think I see a face.
Oh my god, I missed the leaf.
Where is it?
You got this, Dirty We Belief in you.
Cat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everyone grab.
Don't let her go towards the light.
Because I see it.
I see it.
It's a little blue, but I see it.
Oh my god, at least I found its soulmate in that pile.
It has a 100% success rate so far.
It's none of these.
I don't understand.
Oh my god, it's the X, isn't it?
It's that funky X, isn't it?
I don't know where it is.
I think it's under this pile.
There's just so many piles now.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god, it is.
It's a goddamn funky X in here.
Where did I put it?
Wait, where is the funky X?
It's the fucking Kingdom Hearts.
Oh my god, is it underneath all these leaves?
I forgot all about it.
Oh my god, there it is.
It was here all along.
Wait, it's not?
I don't understand.
There's another...
Excuse me?
Is there another funky X in the...
Is it...
Where was it?
Can I see you see it?
Where is it?
No fucking way.
Alright.
There's a fucking leaf somewhere.
There was a three leaf.
Where is it?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
It found its soul made in the pile though.
It's under my door.
desk i must have left it under my desk okay it's fine i will
find the silly guy we'll find you we're gonna find you i
don't remember where it is
okay back to the leaves what the did i make here what What
did I make this?
Okay.
Maybe if I keep rotating it, it'll fucking attach somewhere.
What the fuck is this?
All right, we'll figure that where that goes later.
I'm going to put this here.
I don't know where the fuck that's going to go to.
Oh, okay.
Well, we found this guy's home, at least.
We found his home.
Okay, I take those.
I take those.
Yeah, that's a freebie.
Oh, my gosh, this isn't it?
Oh, it was not this.
It was not this.
Wait.
Oh, I feel...
found it
okay we're getting closer we're getting closer they're all
it's all starting to come together the picture the picture
is coming together guys i
know understand i i'm right out i ran out of pieces oh wait
there's one more okay now now i don't understand Okay, maybe
I'll just do the side shit.
Okay.
Oh my god, I've lost track of the plot.
I'll do the leaves again.
Okay.
Okay, I was in that pile.
I just, I don't know.
There's too many puzzle pieces now.
I, there's just too many puzzle pieces.
Okay, it's none of these.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
You'll try these out just in case.
Just in case.
It would be pretty funny if it was any of these.
Oh, it would be so silly.
Bishop, welcome to tomato farm.
welcome welcome nameless thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you okay i don't know but i don't know anymore
okay i'm just gonna maybe one of them will connect here ha
ha maybe it'll be so funny it'll be so funny whoa at
least i'll have somewhere to start
I'll go see how I'm knitting this for 30 minutes you're a
true big toky thank you with a super chat fire thank you
thank you
yeah I'm going to say I can't keep doing this I I'm so close
I'm so close
There's, I can, I, I know I'm there.
Oh my God, I'm so happy.
I'm so happy every time I hear that click.
There is a God.
When I hear that click, I know there's a God out there.
Just to be sure.
The dopamine.
That's what gets me going Click That's the one thing The
goddamn Click Maybe there's a click right here
Or here Come on, give me anything Anything Or right here
even here or right here or here or right here or either or
maybe here or maybe here or here or here something will
click right okay here oh oh I clicked It clicked, guys.
Guys.
It clicked.
Okay.
Okay, I gotta make sure.
Does it fit these?
Okay, no.
No.
Okay, it's a leaf.
Always a leaf.
Right here.
Or here.
Could be anywhere.
What were we?
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's getting smaller.
The door that held is getting smaller, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's actually getting smaller.
everything is i just i just see it i see the freedom right
around that corner let's see thank you with a super chat
thank you thank you you're not alone my hearing's very good
but from here lots of guys have trouble thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you yeah okay now now i don't
know anymore now now i don't know
Maybe, like, I don't know.
Oh, oh, wait, I abducted someone.
I abducted someone.
I, okay, that's fine.
I'll take that.
I don't know who I took along for the ride.
But apparently I took someone in the pile.
Maybe that's the strat.
We keep fucking abducting people in the pile.
Oh, my God, it is.
Okay, I figured out the strat, guys.
I figured it out.
We'll just keep kidnapping people into the pile.
That's the new strat.
The puzzle sent to me.
Join us.
Okay, wait.
Wait, actually.
Okay, no, I don't even know if this is right side or left
side or down or up.
I don't know.
Oh, oh, thank you.
Here we go, we got more.
New strat, new strat.
We found more.
I'm just trying to figure out where to place this
monstrosity.
Okay, another one.
I'm trying to figure where to place this.
I just keep kidnapping puzzle pieces.
All right, we have this long ass puzzle piece.
Okay, wait.
We're going to go backwards now.
A leaf goes in here.
Okay, there we go.
We got another leaf here, too.
Alright.
If it's none of these leaves, that means it's there.
It connects somewhere.
Okay.
Alright.
my god where does this go where does this even go oh my god
we did it the puzzle sent the bean has found a home okay all
right we did it where you found it
Okay, it's a long boy.
I got it.
I got it in.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, God.
Okay, okay.
Now, now I don't know.
I've lost track of the plot.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't know anymore.
I don't know where else the place anywhere.
Okay.
That has to be...
No?
Okay.
You got that.
Okay, that's a leaf.
That's a leaf right there.
That's a leaf piece.
I know a fucking leaf piece when I see one i think
wait which one's my discarded leaf pile okay i think it's
this i'm pretty sure and then okay okay
we gotta scroll up
okay all right all right there's hope there's hope there's
hope oh that has to be a long piece
okay oh i nailed it i made a castle it made I made a reverse
castle.
It's a reverse castle, guys.
Look at that.
Isn't that beautiful?
It's a fucking reverse castle.
Oh my god, there you go.
It's like a little melatonin boost.
A little dopamine boost, too.
It's just everything.
It's a boost of everything.
It's hitting me in all my fucking brains.
in all the hemispheres.
She's just saying random words now.
Every single receptor is like, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Okay.
All right, another leaf.
Another leaf down.
Okay, one more leaf down.
It has to.
be a leaf right
yeah it has to be for a leaf
does this go anywhere oh oh i'm
gonna do my pal strat
oh nice oh my god oh my god it's a city it's a reverse city
i'm speed running this now okay I got it.
I got it.
It's a tower now.
I got the tower in.
Wait, where the fuck are the other?
Okay, there's the side pieces.
Okay, it's time.
I'm putting everything in the pile.
Come on.
Find each other.
Find your soulmate.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, I forgot about these guys.
I forgot these guys existed.
I was just gonna forgot I had these pieces.
Nice.
Okay.
It's a final countdown.
Here.
Okay.
one more leaf oh
my god there's now more side pieces than leaves we've made
it
okay has to be this this one okay
no this one no
okay oh my god the last leaf oh sorry the second last leaf
We need... Oh, wait, not the third lastly.
How many leaves are there?
Oh my god, I have three more leaf pieces.
I didn't even notice.
Okay.
Then...
Here we go.
Here we go, guys.
This is it.
We were here.
I'm trying to figure out the last couple of ones.
Oh my god, it was this one.
The one last three.
The last three.
The rule of them all.
Oh my god.
I wonder what the puzzle's gonna look like after I'm done.
Oh, the one piece.
Oh my god!
It was white!
Congratulations!
I did it!
It took, only took me three hours!
it's a it's beautiful it truly is a work of art we should
hate this in the gallery cute thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you gt let's go oh my god we fucking did it
jakarta thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh
Yo, I didn't realize how painful 200 pieces would be.
I didn't.
Now do a thousand pieces.
Thank you for the super chat.
All right, for it.
Thank you, thank you.
I keep thinking of the super chat.
What if it froze?
Luckily, it has auto-save.
It luckily has auto-save, guys.
I'm okay.
It's okay.
Guys, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, so
300 pieces next week, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
thank you, thank you, oh my god, I'm free, I found the door
out of hell.
it's just that easy i it's just it's just that easy guys it
really yeah yeah this is my painting it's called rabbit in a
snowstorm it's very deep do you see the symbolism in this
painting in this puzzle oh my god oh tired to a thousand
pieces Oh, it's so un- I would love to, dragons.
I would love to do a thousand pieces, but it's so
unfortunate that this game only has a 200-piece limit.
Oh, man, that sucks.
Oh, well, guys, better luck next time.
It's so unfortunate.
Oh, man.
Oh, shucks.
Oh, unlucky.
I would have loved to do a thousand pieces.
But yet, unfortunately, this game can only do 200.
That's the max.
That's your answer.
Thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Do five 200-piece puzzles.
They even super chat That's too easy Come on guys I already
did it Where's the fun in that If I just do it five more
times It's just gonna get so boring With how fast I do it
You know It's gonna
You know guys It's just so It's gonna be so boring I was
just gonna be like Because I already have experience I know
where it all goes now Let's just do this five times in a row
coward leave a super chat thank you thank you Corey but guys
I already did it guys there's the fun in that where's the
freshness of a stream if I just do the same thing again
where is the challenge hey guys I hope you guys enjoyed
today's stream I followed the light and now I'm free I'm
gonna I'm gonna head off lots of work to do as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stayed up for me head
to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye